in a 60 mm in Phoenix Arizona and that
means we are just one hour away from
president Trump's remarks at a rally
there his first political event since
the violence in charlottesville ten days
ago vice president Mike Pence will
introduce the president he'll address
the crowd soon and we're going to bring
that to you live thousands of protesters
have descended on downtown Phoenix and
we're going to show you that scene in
just a moment the president's remarks
tonight followed last night's address to
the nation on the new way forward in
Afghanistan for more on what we might
expect to hear let's go to Mike Emanuel
live at the Phoenix Convention Center of
Mike well Kimberly good evening the
people here inside this convention
senator have waited all day for this
presidential rally in fact some gathered
out on the sidewalk as early as 2:00
a.m. local time and when temperatures
hit 107 degrees by mid-afternoon it has
certainly turned out to be an endurance
test but we're still seeing plenty of
smiles all throughout the Convention
Center I asked some folks late today
what they were hoping to hear from
President Trump tonight I'm looking to
hear him reaffirm things that he
promised on the campaign trail and maybe
a little bit of clarification how he
intends to get there being that there's
so much opposition to him I want
assurances that he will continue on with
the same policies that he was elected by
I just wanna hear what he has to say
continue to say what he's been saying
through our country since he started
running this campaign there have been a
lot of questions about what President
Trump may or may not say about Arizona's
two Republican senators the president
has clashed with both John McCain and
Jeff Flake he's clearly been upset with
McCain for being the vote that killed
health care reform in the Senate in
flake has been a vocal critic and the
president has fired back saying the
flake is weak on borders and crime and
called him a non-factor in the Senate
and there is clearly a lot of anxiety
and Republican leadership if the
president attacks Jeff Flake tonight
with flake expected to have a tough
reelection bid next year vice president
Mike Pence says we should expect the
president to lay out the agenda when
Congress returns in September issues
like tax reform or the
these tax cuts money for that border
wall and of course scrapping Obamacare
in about an hour or so we'll get a sense
of exactly what is on the president's
mind Kimberly
all right thanks Mike and protests were
expected tonight and there are many
demonstrations outside the mayor of
Phoenix issued this warning last night
to those attending the rally and to
those outside we want to give you every
opportunity to express your First
Amendment rights no matter what your
opinion happens to be however
as mayor of the City of Phoenix I am
expecting you to be civil respectful and
peaceful
Jonathan hunt is there so let's get more
from him now on what the scene is like
inside hi Jonathan hey Kimberly it's a
loud crowd it's a raucous crowd outside
the Convention Center but it is so far a
civil crowd as the mayor asked these
protesters to be there are I would
estimate several thousand of them
directly outside the Convention Center
right now they are being kept behind
police placed barriers a street width
apart from the Trump supporters who have
been filing into the Convention Center
having waited outside for many hours we
have heard the usual chance that you
have come to know from the anti Trump
supporters and the the pro Trump crab
going into the convention shouting back
the slogans that we've heard many times
before now there are something like
3,000 members of the Phoenix Police
Department in total pretty much all of
those are either on duty or on call
tonight from our experience Kimberly
covering all the protests that we saw
during the presidential election
campaign the real flashpoint comes after
the rally rather than before or during
it that is when the Trump supporters
file out their met on the streets by the
anti-trump protesters and that tends to
be if there is any trouble when it
happens the Phoenix Police Department
have appealed for everybody like the
mayor did to be civil and respectful
tonight we'll see if that happens the
rally not obviously underway in terms of
mr. Trump speaking
yet when it does are then those prose
supporters will file out and as I say
that is when there could be a flashpoint
and the potential for trouble but the
Phoenix Police Department very much on
alert for any violence they say they
will crack down on it very quickly
should it happen Kimberly okay so thank
you for that Jonathan one we see the
scene there as Jonathan has said it in
terms of the people outside the mayor's
really urge a sense of you know calm and
caution for people to be there to
peacefully express themselves but not to
escalate to violence like we have seen
in some other situations and of course
this coming on really a tumultuous time
for the country with Charlottesville
what do you expect tonight
well I don't know what to expect
obviously this is kind of a you know an
explosive situation because you have
lots of protesters not just a few and
you have them actually coming from very
different perspective there is a protest
in support of police scheduled for
tonight in Phoenix you also have the
Jewish community rallying they are
saying never again then you have the
anti-trump people then you have the
anti-fascist people coming as well so
there's all sorts of elements there and
you don't know how they combine Kimberly
is what I'm trying to say I do think one
important aspect is you said this ten
days after what we saw in
Charlottesville and there was the
potential for a specific fuse that could
ignite some of these crowds and that was
whether or not President Trump would
pardon former sheriff joe arpaio but now
our pile has said he's not coming and
what we heard from the White House today
was there will be no action on a
potential pardon of our pile so anytime
today so I guess that means not at this
event the the real tension comes with
internal Republican politics people like
John McCain people like Jeff Flake are
not fans of the president Blake has a
best-selling book out the president's
attacked flake he's attacked McCain
there's an ongoing fight with Senate
Majority Leader McConnell in specific
about the idea that you're undermining a
20-18 candidate for the Senate from the
White House but we'll see how that goes
I don't think that's going to spark any
protest okay so Dana you know we've had
that you know set the scene in terms of
what's happening and what the you know
expectation
what's the president's message be given
you know he had a very successful
national security speech that went over
very well and now he's coming into a
situation where yes he has supporters in
Arizona but also there's you know a
hotbed in terms of you know immigration
issues and things that he's been
criticized on well I've been frustrated
with the rallies just from the news
making perspective because it is just a
great opportunity for any president to
be able to drive forward a message for
the next day so he he gave the National
Security speech last night tomorrow he
speaks to the American Legion I do think
in the top five to seven minutes he
should refer back to that speech so that
he can continue on that theme for eight
of you in addition he also toured the
border this morning so obviously that's
going to have to be something that comes
up I do think that he'll have some sort
of reference to charlottesville like he
did on Monday night doesn't necessarily
have to be too specific this is a very
different audience it's not the military
has to sit there and not clap this will
be a very excited crowd he has a really
high approval rating in Arizona so I
expect that he'll enjoy the speech but I
I went I would be curious what he
thought about his own speech last night
because it did get some pretty high
marks except on substance it's been sort
of picked apart we'll talk about that in
the B block and I wonder how he actually
feels about that but he didn't tweet
today so I don't know
he's been unusually quiet but again you
make the great point that he's going to
be in front of a really welcoming crowd
people that are really feeling the
president so he should get some
enthusiasm and energy from that just one
quick follow-up under some concern that
perhaps if he makes any comments
specifically about the Senators day I
believe I heard the esteemed Brian
Kilmeade say that on best list earlier
today I usually provide transcript they
slide him under your door yeah thanks
for reading
I thought you what do you think Dana
he's got that away from that message
discipline well I don't know it depends
on I mean he'll just do what he wants to
do I mean there are consequences for
doing that and but he might think that
that actually benefits him
senator Blake is not going to be there
tonight but I think I know the governor
saw him at the airport but I think that
that's also fine I think that they agree
on a lot more than they disagree on and
in fact the president will want and can
count on his vote meeting senator flake
when it comes to tax reform this fall if
that's the most important issue I would
just like drive forward on that
all right Brian you got some gas left in
the tank don't you I've been here since
3:00 a.m. yeah okay I'm fascinated
all right I didn't realize he didn't
tweet it all today and if you just take
a look at what's happened Saturday his
tweets were right on the money in the
Boston protests the Boston police
responded gray I thought he was
he actually saluted the protesters who
showed up to speak out against hate and
then you have the Monday speech which
was fine during the day which was
without news they would asides the ban
in situation going and then today
there's no tweets to get you off message
so we were able to talk about
Afghanistan when other networks wanted
to pivot and talk something negative
back from they had to go back to
Charlottesville they had nothing that
day so they go on and reach for this New
York Times article about McConnell and
say look at the friction on the right
that doesn't get you ratings that
doesn't that doesn't uh that does not
fix
yeah it's News Alert I would just add
this can you imagine if he opens up and
does what you do for the first two
sentences of first seven minutes and
then instead of taking aim at flake
talks about the wall in the need for a
billion dollars a 1.6 billion that the
house wants forward the need for tax
reform and then he goes after McCaskill
tester and Manchin and said you have to
go and face the people in your state
that I won and you got to win reelection
and you know I have the agenda to turn
this country around and still you're
marching along with Senator Schumer
who's done nothing for you except
destroy the party magic if he does that
every every Democrat will pass out that
means every there'll be bodies all over
the streets of New York City okay
fires yes not so much I go here I go Oh
expired morning fire and the heat you
expired so expired
interesting don't make don't make our
viewers happy I know come back to life
all right Greg so what do you expect
from him tonight and are you gonna agree
with the smart why use great shock he's
cold on you're the only one we haven't
closed I know you're bright it's good to
see you
it really is it's so funny that you do a
show called Fox and Friends when you're
neither a fox and you have no friends
that really hurts me okay benefited you
challenged you challenged me to insult
you by the way insulted you making smart
if that's not even notes I was small
talk before the show that he said please
insult me so I thought I didn't so he
kidding
I am through with you I wrote Kennedy
until right here in the corner I saw a
box of French he's no Fox and he has no
friends my god but you don't always find
her I really don't know what to say
about this because get this it hasn't
happened yet
we're going to do four segments we're
going to do four segments America on
something that hasn't happened yet
what would I like this what has impact
yes I would like this I would like I
would like Donald Trump maybe to come
out there and be self-deprecating and
funny because I've seen him be funny but
not necessarily self-deprecating to say
that he's not perfect I'm a businessman
I'm not a spoken word poet you know I
you know I I'm a guy who does things I
build things
I don't really say things I build things
I've said this for he is the inverse
Obama Obama was amazing with words not
so much with deeds Trump is a guy who
acted he's a man of action but his words
are inartful so it's it's that's what
we're dealing with the complete opposite
when it comes to something like this
your preconceived assumptions are going
to drive your conclusions no matter what
he says if you think he's a racist and
Satan and Hitler all wrapped up into one
whatever he says it's just going to
drive you crazy when people applaud
you're just gonna go get madder and
madder and madder and that's just
there's no way to treat that's if he
shouldn't but Greg I don't think you're
correct because never in Poland he
delivered the speech his critics say was
pretty good but he got him his own way
then he had that speech last night some
people don't like the D Kelly didn't
give out part of his plan is not to give
out detail you know it was hard I think
that if he delivers a speech it will
force his critics to I don't know go to
a test pattern right now as a guest on
this show you're not supposed to
disagree with me we live the get rid of
drugs yeah we are on right I apologize
and actually this top right hydrangea
like no we are actually why whatever I
want your heart is very sweet and polite
to you a little bit of thank you very
much yeah and you have a lot of friends
this one versus meatball over here all
right so one do you expect that there's
again he loves meatballs that's kind of
a cute term do you expect that there are
going to be like violent protests from
people like the anti-shah
and that there's going to be something
that the president does a good job and
these groups like react and have
violence after that erupts exacting it
that's going to take away from what he's
doing or really gonna but you know but
he doesn't control that me I don't I
don't think in fact they'll react to his
speech well they think about but I think
that you know what the mayor grants Greg
Stanton we saw him at the star of the
show what he said America is hurting
because Trump doused racial tensions
with gasoline so it's kind of and
speaking to a great one right it's like
a pregame show right anything up in the
pregame here for this big matchup you'd
say well gee whiz you know this is a key
event because of what happened in
Charlottesville and I think that brings
added attention added pressures to the
president's performance tonight last
night really he said some things about
race and Charles Ville at the very top I
was and I thought boy he's taken an easy
out here is using the military as a prop
but tonight it was just about Trump and
Trump and his base at a very passionate
loud rally
how does race play into that picture
well he's at home field advantage in
terms of this is a very supportive group
that's going to be I brought anything
very vocal they're going to give him
they're gonna be the last track they
clap track they're gonna love what he's
saying I think it's a good image for him
Dana in terms of talking about the wall
and what he wants to achieve like Brian
said because the country sees then there
are people that support this yes though
remember it was in Arizona where McCain
said during the campaign and there was a
negative comment about President Obama
and McCain on the trail had to say look
we don't do that here so sometimes a
crowd can can push you right into that
zone I mean the president could might
decide that that doesn't hurt him to be
there but also I think that when you
spoke to the military last night and he
said like this is this is the best
experiment because everybody is equal
here and he was being a president for
all Americans and so when he's speaking
tonight and I think that hopefully we'll
keep that in mind but you know when
you're there's a rally and that's great
but you're you have a lot of people out
there who are anxious and frustrated and
if you want to add you if you want to
poke them sir you can or you can choose
to not poke them which would be
different just to
because Juan brought up the quote by the
mayor of Phoenix accusing Trump of
dousing racial tensions with gasoline
that would be I think that would make
sense if you're in a bubble because
Trump didn't give the perfect answer
he didn't give nearly the perfect answer
and then he fell into an antagonistic
trap with the press and started fighting
with them after not giving the perfect
answer I wouldn't call that stoking
racial tension I think that's a bit of
an exaggeration but that's just my
opinion stoking dousing I know what
you're saying yes but your best thing
was self-deprecating I think that would
be the best thing to do he indicated he
could do that yesterday it's too late
goes it's too late Brian another taste I
don't want to make it different then
itself deprecated or not I don't think I
don't think this is OK anyway live shot
they're a phoenix arizona